natürlich ist es human geboten Menschen
in Not zu helfen ist doch gar keine
Frage aber an welchem Punkt kommt man
einfach an Grenzen und das habe ich im
Gespräch mit Herrn Schärf eben deutlich
gemerkt obwohl einfach sagen müssen gut
es ist eine Sache in Berlin zu
beschließen dass wir das machen und die
ganz andere Sache ist es aber vor Ort
umzusetzen weil du dann irgendwann
schlicht vor der Frage stehst wo kommt
denn eigentlich die nächste Turnhalle
das nächste Gebäude die nächste Kita der
nächste Kita Platz die nächsten Lehrer
Lehrerinnen wo kommt sozusagen die ganze
Infrastruktur her die du auch brauchst
wenn du sagst wir kümmern uns um
Flüchtlinge
der Parteifreund aus Miltenberg und
Landrat hat ja den schönen Satz wir
schaffen das nicht wiederholt
ich habe den 2015 Bord gleich benutzt
und der verfiel Ärger bekommen weil da
hineingelesen wird dass man es nicht
schaffen will also in Wahrheit nicht
helfen möchte ich glaube aber das ist
tatsächlich gut ist die kommunalen
Unterstützungssysteme mit ihrer
Leistungskraft zu überprüfen und zu
fragen was können die noch und wo ich
einfach die Grenze erreicht ich sehe da
im Moment vier Systeme die mindestens an
der Leistungsgrenze sind teilweise
überfordert sind das erste ist
ironischerweise unsere eigene
ausländerbürokratie wir können die
ganzen Anträge schlicht gar nicht mehr
bearbeiten der Städtetag hat zu Recht
darauf hingewiesen wenn er uns nicht
dramatisch von diesen unfassbar
komplizierten Rechtsregeln im
Ausländerrecht entlastet werden wir die
Anträge einfach gar nicht bearbeiten und
ich habe riesen Probleme in meiner Stadt
mit Leute die sagen ich will morgen
arbeiten ich kriege aber keine
Arbeitserlaubnis weil ich kriege keinen
Aufenthaltserlaubnis und eine Ausländer
haben sich niemand mehr da der die Akten
angucken könnte also ich hatte
Wunsch nicht da es gibt die Leute
einfach nicht und es wandert auch
niemand ein der deutsches Ausländerrecht
kann und morgen in meinem Ausländeramt
arbeiten könnte dafür ist es nämlich zu
deutsche zu kompliziert gibt es aber
nicht ja das erste System des eindeutig
über der Belastungsgrenze ist und vom
Zusammenbruch steht was dramatische
Auswirkungen hat für alle die es
brauchen und das zweite System
dass ich jetzt drüben gerade mit
Demonstrationen merke dass das
überfordert wird die Kinderbetreuung das
war eh schon knapp das sind viele Sachen
zusammengekommen
unter anderem Corona und
Landesregelungen
Standards aber dass wir da jetzt in die
Gruppen dann immer noch mehr Kinder
aufnehmen sollen die neu hinzukommen und
in keiner Bedarfsplanung dabei waren
logisch Alter keiner vorhergesehen führt
dazu dass die Öffnungszeiten gekürzt
werden dass die Personalschlüssel nicht
gehalten werden dass die Kita ständig
aufhören dass die ganzen Eltern die
arbeiten wollen auf dem Marktplatz in
Tübingen Demos machen und sagen das geht
doch nicht sein Rückfall in die
Steinzeit wie hier mit Frauen und
Familien umgegangen wird durchaus
einfach weil die Betreuung nicht mehr
möglich Betreuung ist nicht mehr zu
gewährleisten auch hier Problem wir
finden das Personal nicht die
Ausschreibungen laufen leer wir haben
allein bei der Stadt Tübingen über 100
unbesetzte Stellen im Kita-Bereich und
es gibt die Leute einfach nicht und der
dritte Bereich der an der Grenze läuft
oder drüber ist je nach Region sehr
unterschiedlich die Unterbringung wir
hatten eine Riesenwelle der
Hilfsbereitschaft wo Leute Wohnraum der
offenbar untergenutzt oder leer war zur
Verfügung gestellt haben das aber jetzt
rum da kommt kaum noch was und jetzt
geht's wieder in Richtung Turnhallen wo
Landratsamt das will ich auf keinen Fall
ich habe mich die rote Linie andere sind
da schon drüber und müssen wieder die
Tonnen belegen wohlgemerkt für die
langfristige Unterbringung also nicht
mal für vier Wochen sondern für die
kommunale Unterbringung die auf Jahre
ausgelegt ist also Jahre im Turnhallen
heißt es das ist sicherlich jenseits der
Belastungsgrenze und das vierte System
ist die Integrationskraft
im organisierten Bereich Deutschkurse
Integrationskurse alles was man halt
braucht um die Leute in unserer
Gesellschaft ankommen zu lassen ich
rationiert und steht auf lange Zeit gar
nicht zur Verfügung auch da wieder die
Leute sind nicht da dies machen können
so und wenn man sich das mal eingesteht
dass das alles nicht mehr verfügbar ist
dass da keine Reserven da sind und da
ehrlich darüber reden dann kann man über
Alternativen sprechen was sind die
Optionen ich nehme mal eine raus ich
habe jetzt in meiner Stadt gesagt und
ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich das
Richter wieder aus der Hand schlagen
aber ich verfüge jetzt per städtische
Allgemeinverfügung dass alle die drauf
warten dass sie in Aufenthaltsrecht
kriegen für das nächste
jahresaufenthaltsrecht haben ich habe
keine Leute waren bis zu prüfen das gilt
jetzt einfach mal Unterschrift Palmer
Oberbürgermeister doch das Dokument
existiert jetzt gucken wir mal was
passiert ist der nächste Richter kommt
gilt es erstmal in Tübingen haben die
Leute jedenfalls was in der Hand und ein
anderes Beispiel wenn ich die Kitas
nicht mehr mit Personal bestücken kann
dann wäre es vielleicht gar nicht falsch
zu sagen wer jetzt gerade aus der
Ukraine kommt und dann noch mal 100.000
kommen und nochmal 100.000 vielleicht
brauchen die keinen Rechtsanspruch nach
deutschem Standard den haben sie im
Moment auf Unterbringung in
ganztages-kitas mit Personalschlüssel
wie wir das jetzt halt gewohnt sind
sondern vielleicht ist da auch okay wenn
die 15 Stunden eine Spielgruppe selbst
organisiert in städtischen Räumen machen
reicht den Kindern möglicherweise mal
fürs nächste halbe Jahr dass die hier
aufgenommen sind darf ich aber nicht
verboten Rechtsanspruch die müssen in
die völlig überfüllte Kita und ich muss
dann die Seiten zusammen kürzen und das
das reduziert irgendwann die Akzeptanz
sagen ich kann ja nicht mehr arbeiten zu
Recht und hier auf der anderen Seite
sagen muss ja aber ich muss die jetzt
auch noch zusätzlich unterbringen dann
kann es zu dem Punkt kommen würde würde
das Band überdehnt wird und die
Hilfsbereitschaft einfach bricht
deswegen offen reden über diese Optionen
die wir haben das heißt letztlich werden
erzählen uns der Unfall glaube ich viele
Dinge es merke ich immer wieder und die
tiefer man einsteigt umso mehr
das ist völlig lebensfremd was wir uns
da also sehr wünschenswert aber
lebensfremd sie haben gerade genickt
Frau Balti erleben Sie das auch so wie
Herr Palma das Beschreiben natürlich
also wir haben ich sag immer also in der
größten Not entstehen ja immer die
größten Ideen und man lernt die
stärksten Menschen kennen die auch
bereit sind wirklich viel viel zu
leisten für diese Gesellschaft und dann
scheitert man an der Bürokratie und an
der Verwaltung also das erleben wir
jeden Tag bei uns natürlich in Neukölln
ich kann mein schlechtes Beispiel nennen
wir haben schöne große Schulen die haben
sehr viel Platz auch nach der Schule
auch im Nachmittag oder am frühen bis
späten Abend wenn diese Gebäude nicht
mehr genutzt werden und alleine die
nutzfahr zu machen für Projekte oder
auch für ehrenamtliche Initiativen das
ist ein bürokratischer Akt und es ist
teilweise eine Unmöglichkeit dass man
dann irgendwann anfängt zu sagen ich
lasse das jetzt mal das hat so viel Zeit
gekostet irgendwie daran rumzubaggern
das muss irgendwie viel größer gelöst
werden aber wir müssen das irgendwie
lösen und also mit in vielen in allen
Bereichen ist das tatsächlich so und wir
setzen uns natürlich Standards die uns
natürlich dann auch sehr schnell daran
hindern innovativ und neu und schnell
und anders zu denken unser gesamtes
Bildungssystem ist ein Problem ja oder
wenn ich jetzt von von Kitas höre ich
meine warum sollte wir schaffen ja auch
keine Anreize dass Leute überhaupt
diesen Beruf des Erziehers wählen wollen
ja und und wenn ich unsere Lehrerin
angucke die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
meiner Kinder sind ja meistens Frauen
selten Männer gerade in der Grundschule
warum müssen 30 Kinder in einer Klasse
beschult werden warum kann man nicht
versuchen neu zu denken und auch
wirklich zuzulassen dass die Menschen
die diese Arbeit jeden Tag machen ihre
Ideen einbringen und man da flexibel ist
weil es einfach unmöglich ist
gerade drin sind wirklich ein sozusagen
gelebt im Alltag in gelebter deutscher
Wirklichkeit Herr Stegner der
Rechtsanspruch um einfach mal vorne
anzufangen hat der Palma Recht wenn er
sagt irgendwie es kann doch nicht sein
dass jedes Kind einer Flüchtling Familie
beispielsweise den gleichen
Rechtsanspruch hat wie so haben sie es
glaube ich Zitat gesagt wie das Kind
einer Ärztin die in Tübingen zum
Beispiel lebt und schon immer hier
gewohnt hat warum sind wir da so
furchtbar bürokratisch und wollen
sozusagen immer die reine leere mit der
Konsequenz dass dann irgendwann selbst
die empathische Oberärztin sagt wir
Freunde tut mir leid das geht hier so
nicht mehr weil ich kann mein Beruf gar
nicht mehr ausüben weil es keine Kita
mehr gibt ich glaube dass wenn Humanität
gegen Bürokratie steht und in
Notsituation ich will auch ein Beispiel
weiterhin wenn ich darf was mich sehr
beeindruckt hat ich habe ein zeugen von
Untersuchungsausschuss gehabt gesagt er
war an dem Tag als der Flughafen Kabul
geräumt wurde in Lebensgefahr die Leute
da hatten schon alles mit einer Frau und
zwei kleinen Kindern hat in der Ausreise
Genehmigung des
Verteidigungsministeriums und der
Soldaten dort kontrolliert hat gesagt
wie das hast du nicht ausgedruckt hat
ihn zurück gewesen mit der
Maschinenpistole in der Hand sozusagen
weil das nicht ausgedrückt hat am
Flughafen ist schon keiner etwas aus das
ist ein Beispiel dass wir bürokratische
Systeme haben Vorschriften haben die in
Notsituationen glaube ich nicht taugen
und wo man dann sagen muss jetzt hilft
das muss ja nicht auf ewig so bleiben
aber dass man in 19 jedenfalls muss
pragmatisch geholfen werden das Land das
den wirksamsten Wirkstoff gegen kovitz
entwickelt hat hat gleichzeitig die
meisten Formulare gehabt für die Tests
und für die Impfung sozusagen das eine
ist gut und das andere ist überflüssig
und uns davon ein bisschen zu trennen
ist aber eine sehr lange deutsche
Tradition die Konditionen übrigens die
ampelkondition ist auch deswegen
zusammengekommen weil wir das im Bereich
Ausländerrecht ändern wollen und das ist
der Palma beschrieben weil diese vier
Punkte zeigen eigentlich dass wir das
ein bisschen sortieren müssen dass wir
humanitäre Hilfe dass er dafür sorgen
sollte arbeiten können ganz viele die
sich beklagen dass wir zusammen haben
übersehen dass die Leute daran gehindert
haben zu arbeiten alles was Menschen in
Arbeit bringt muss man doch befürworten
ist und wenn jetzt Erdbeben kommen und
wir machen lange Visa
Verfahren dann werden ganz wenige kommen
können also wird man irgendwelche
Notsituationen akzeptieren müssen und
sagen die kriegen jetzt ein
vereinfachtes Förderprogramm oder sowas
ist die kommen dürfen sonst passiert
nochmal Rechtsanspruch und da noch mal
zu bleiben werden
weil die die dagegen sind sagen wir
wollen natürlich die Qualitätsstandards
nicht auf Dauer ändern das sind ja eher
Notmaßnahmen dass man das nicht anwendet
praktische Anwendung würde eher von von
Pragmatismus reden und nicht davon dass
wir Rechtsnorm
verändert wer möchte das nicht naja also
sind immer die die über Nebenwirkungen
reden und wir haben natürlich ein sehr
fachrechtliches System deshalb haben wir
ja auch gesagt der Macht von der
Verfügung die wir uns sympathisch ist an
der Stelle jedenfalls im ersten Punkt
ersten Punkt wenn das vom Gericht
kassiert wird darf das nicht weiter so
machen so wird das ja sein und dann
müssen wir und alle gehen von
endurokalisierung mindestens in dem Feld
wo es darum geht wo manität und fragt
man das muss sie als Politik sie sind
doch der gesetzgebende Teil wir können
doch Gesetze schlicht ändern an die
halten sich dann auch Richter natürlich
ist das natürlich nicht weil sie immer
mehr hätten dafür finden müssen
sozusagen das zu machen und theoretisch
ist jeder für Entbürokratisierung und
wenn es praktisch wird ist das Interesse
a betroffen oder das Interesse B
betroffen wir sind ja auch eine
Ellbogengesellschaft wir sind
theoretisch sind wir immer sehr
großzügig aber wenn es dann praktisch
wird ist es schwieriger also da muss man
verwerben dann anderes Thema was ist
gerade angesprochen haben ganz
praktische gelebte Wirklichkeit die
Möglichkeit zu arbeiten
ich weiß dass in Dänemark mittlerweile
korrigieren Sie mich wenn ich was
falsches sage in Dänemark eine soziale
demokratische Regierung übrigens sagt
jeder der bei uns asylbe kommt hat die
Verpflichtung zu arbeiten ich finde es
wunderbar wenn die Leute gut wenn die
Leute die arbeiten wollen das wollen wir
uns die meisten auch arbeiten können für
das verhindert hat das war mit der Union
nicht zu machen ich habe lange noch mit
den Verhandlungen geführt
doch gar nicht egal weil wir das jetzt
machen warum wollen die das nicht haben
gehen ja doch wieder alle zurück wenn
wir stehen jetzt wenn wir die jetzt
Sprachkurse machen lassen wenn wir die
jetzt arbeiten lassen dann integrieren
die sich vorher ist doch auch egal wenn
wenn Leute erstmal hier sind können Sie
doch einfach arbeiten das finde ich in
jeder der Hinsicht sinnvoll der Million
Monate lang in Wohnheim sitzen nicht
beschäftigt sind dazu haben oder andere
Dinge kommen die nicht auf gute Gedanken
und deswegen finde ich die Arbeitszeit
wir brauchen sie auch wir brauchen
Fachkräfte warum machen wir das nicht
verstehen
die Dinge dauern ein bisschen länger das
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen oder
freiwillig
werfen
also was sagt das muss da ehrlicherweise
sagen da darf man sich auch nicht zu
viel Illusionen machen ja also nicht
jeder kommt als protestantischer würde
ich auf die Welt es gibt auch Menschen
natürlich
die Deutschen so ist sollte man auch
nicht unterstellen nein
machen wir schicken manchmal Leute nach
Hause Familie mit Kindern die hier
geboren sind weil man leicht an die Hand
kommt und die Straftätern die man nicht
so leicht dran kommt
also wir haben eine sehr engagierte
nicht Zwangsarbeit sehr engagierte
Community in der Flüchtlingsarbeit es
ist ganz klares Ziel die Leute zu
integrieren da gibt's viel Unterstützung
Tübingen ich da jetzt glaube ich nicht
richtig irgendwie da rechts oder so böse
zu sein und trotzdem kann ich Ihnen
folgendes Ergebnis
sechs Jahren nach 2016 mitteilen von den
erwerbsfähigen geflüchteten in Tübingen
gezielt 2021 also vor ukraine-zugang
wenn wir jetzt von 2015 zwei 16 diese
Jahre genau also 2021 ermittelt wie
viele Arbeiten von denen die nach zwei
15 gekommen sind
25% sind sozialversicherungspflichtig
beschäftigt also die erwerbsfähigen das
sind nicht die Kinder dabei
25% sind in irgendeiner Art von
Qualifikationen Fortbildung
Integrationskurs was auch immer und 50%
sind schlicht nicht tätig in keiner
Weise das sind die Zahlen die aus
Tübingen großartiger Fortschritt
gegenüber dem was behauptet worden kann
ich nicht so sehen also finden Sie 25%
Sozialversicherung in den USA
geben und dass das passiert
Daten zu klären also wir reden von
Menschen die 25 16 gekommen sind ja
überwiegend weil davon
wie lange durften die nicht arbeiten das
hängt von der fahrkonstellation ab also
die Syrer die subsidiären Schutz hatten
durften sehr schnell arbeiten sehr
schnell heißt nach Wochen also meistens
durften eben nicht arbeiten die
Unternehmer haben sich bei uns beklagt
der Union deutlich näher stehen dass wir
nun das immer verändert hat setzt das
endlich durch die ampelkration hat es
einen Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben wir
wollen das machen das ist klar dass die
Union das alles war aber jetzt nein
25% sozialversicherungspflichtig
beschäftigt bei Leuten haben die
gekommen sind als Flüchtlinge kein Wort
Deutsch gesprochen haben integriert
werden müssen ich finde das das muss
mehr werden auf alle Fälle aber das ist
doch also
sehr unzufrieden ich finde sechs Jahre
nachdem ich immer noch keiner Tätigkeit
nachzugehen als erwerbsfähige Person
finde ich keine gute
Integrationsleistungen dürfen
Arbeiten
man hat zugestimmt für die sicheren
Herkunftsländer im Balkan gegen die weit
gehen die Schleifen der Arbeitsverbot
seit 2016 sind die meisten
Arbeitsverbote Weg jetzt aber nochmal zu
dem Ergebnis sie dürfen damit es nicht
das Gesamtbild also das sind die Zahlen
insgesamt ich finde es sehr schwach weil
sechs Jahre muss ich gegangen ist
bestimmt keine gute
integrationsvoraussetzung wenn es
richtig ja ich finde es viel zu wenig in
USA arbeiten nach drei Monaten 90
Prozent weil anders kann man sich nicht
über Wasser halten halte ich ehrlich
gesagt verbesser wenn man da arbeitet
jetzt habe ich konkrete
ja viele sind illegal wie Sie wissen
dürfen
aber wir haben zum Teil zwei Jobs das
ist die ganze Wahrheit dazu die
Ausgangslage war ja wir wollen die alle
Arbeiten ich habe gesagt Mensch wir
haben so viele unbesetzte Stellen im
Reinigungsbereich bei der Stadt findet
mehr auch keiner ne gehen wir mal ganz
viel mit unserer
Integrationsarbeit auf die Leute zu wir
bieten den Job an der Stadtverwaltung
Tübingen ordentlich nach TVöD bezahlt
ich halt Reinigungsarbeit ja viele
Menschen die aus der Türkei gekommen
sind machen diese Tätigkeiten seit 10 20
30 Jahren sehr zufällig
von denen die wir da gefragt haben war
nach zwei Monaten keiner mehr da die
haben eine Probearbeit gemacht war nach
vier Wochen aber nach zwei Monaten war
kein einziger Syrer mehr da und hat
diese Arbeit weiter angenommen und ich
habe mit manchen gesprochen mit dem
Malermeister gesprochen erzählt ich habe
eine schönes Haus hier von dem Menschen
zu Vermietung bekommen ich habe fünf
Kinder da kriege ich so und so viel Geld
wenn ich jetzt arbeite stehe ich nicht
besser da ich bin zwar ausgebildeter
Malermeister aber ich bin jetzt lieber
bei meinen Kindern zu Hause den Luxus
würde sich vielleicht mancher der hier
geboren ist auch gerne leisten ich will
nur sagen die andere Seite der sich auch
manchmal die leistete
uns auch zurecht darüber auf aber die
Gesellschaft insgesamt wird damit nicht
mehr funktioniert und ich finde wir
sollten schon mal ehrlich darüber
sprechen das ist offenkundig und zu
reichen die Anreizsysteme sind die
verboten aber das da auch
Motivationsprobleme bestehen die wir
nicht angehen weil die Moment wo man das
so offen ausspricht wie ich würde mir
schon sehr komisch angeguckt darf man
das sagen es gibt sicher nicht arbeiten
wollen muss ja doch ein afdler sein der
sowas sagt nee einfach die Möglichkeit
die gibt gut aber
ich habe noch mal eine Frage zu den 50
zu den 50%, die nicht bereit waren aus
welchen Gründen auch immer zu arbeiten
sozialversicherungspflichtig haben sie
Erkenntnisse darüber ob die aber
trotzdem gearbeitet haben also ob sie so
trotzdem arbeiten aber nicht aber nicht
sozialversicherungspflichtig also wenn
sie schwarz arbeiten wissen wir es nicht
aber einer legalen Beschäftigung gehen
diese geht diese Hälfte jedenfalls nicht
nach sein ja das ist ja das hat ja auch
oft eine Ursache es ist ja nicht so dass
die Leute nicht arbeiten wollen weil sie
nichts verdienen wollen sondern dass das
über uns beobachten und das ist auch
keine neue Erkenntnis ist dass wir halt
den ganzen schwarzarbeitsmarkt haben wo
die Menschen ausgebeutet werden aber
trotzdem eine Möglichkeit haben Geld zu
verdienen in einem gewissen Umfang wie
schnell möglich ist und unbürokratisches
machen sehr viele Menschen deswegen das
kriegen wir auch regelmäßig mit bei uns
in Neukölln wenn wir da gewisse Einsätze
haben und dann auch eben Menschen
erleben wie sie in Bretter verschlingen
untergebracht werden um bei uns auf dem
Bau zu arbeiten und da haben wir auch
eine begrenzte Mittel irgendwie gegen
vorzugehen das ist auch keine neue
Erkenntnis aber auch das ist doch
letztendlich ein ganz breites Feld wo
sehr viele Menschen mittlerweile
arbeiten die zu uns einwandern aus
Südosteuropa oder aus Syrien hergekommen
sind die machen Schwarzarbeit um weil
sie wissen das ist für sie auf die
einzige Möglichkeit dann doch noch so
Geld zu verdienen wie sie sich das mal
vorgestellt haben als sie nach
Deutschland gekommen
weil es tatsächlich so ist also bei
ihnen sind die Reinigungskräfte direkt
bei der Stadt angestellt ja bei uns ist
das nicht so da haben wir mittlerweile
ist das alles auch privatisiert meine
Mutter hat 50 Jahre als Reinigungskraft
für das Land Berlin gearbeitet und kann
deswegen heute von einer einigermaßen
okay in Rente leben das können andere
Frauen und Männer nicht mehr die diese
Arbeit machen und die Reinigungskraft
die zu mir ins Büro kommt ins Amt die
schicke ich immer wieder gleich raus
weil das Pensum was die leisten muss ja
mit drei Jobs damit sie ihre Familie
ernähren kann das ist unmenschlich
wieder und das ist auch ein Bereich den
wir hier sehr stark in Europa gefördert
haben das ist einfach dieser niedrig
arbeitslohnsektor wo die Menschen gar
nicht mehr mit einem Job durchkommen
also es funktioniert das können Sie sich
hier alle nicht vorstellen ja das sind
nämlich ganz ganz das sind das sind das
sind deutsche Alltag und so leben weil
ich weil das Miss fällt mir ein bisschen
wenn wir so ein Bild zeichnen von die
arbeitsunwilligen Syrer die Syrer sind
wenn sie arbeitsunwillig sind genauso
arbeitsunwillig wie jemand der keine
Migrationsgeschichte hat damit wir das
mal so festhalten ja also die Menschen
sind da relativ gleich gestrickt
sozusagen
dass das jetzt irgendwie rechts ist wenn
man sagt der syrische Mensch wollte aber
nicht putzen er wollte halt nicht
also ich will ihm auch gar nicht den
Verdacht aussetzen ich wollte nur noch
mal klarstellen dass wir das überall
finden in der Gesellschaft
eine große Reportage aus dem Wall Street
Journal in Hinterkopf wo genau darüber
geredet wurde und die Frage war warum
sind wir so schlecht bei der Integration
warum kriegen wir Leute nicht in den
Arbeitsmarkt die Frage die wir
amerikanischen Kollegen Kollegen
gestellt haben war wie kann es sein dass
Deutschland Jahr für Jahr
rekordeinwanderung hat und trotzdem
einen unglaublichen Fachkräftemangel und
da reden wir nicht nur über
qualifizierte hochqualifizierte Arbeit
sondern wir tun uns offensichtlich auch
schwer Stellen nachzusetzen für die ist
gar keine große Qualifikation braucht
und die Frage die die stellten war genau
die und sagten in der amerikanischen
Arbeitslosen Statistik und ich bin
weiter von entfernt die amerikanische
Arbeitswirklichkeit großartig zu finden
weil ich all die abkunde da auch kenne
aus eigenem Leben und anschauen aber in
der amerikanischen Arbeitslosen
Statistik ist es schlicht oder greifen
so dass Einwanderer deutlich unter
repräsentiert sind ja und in der
deutschen ist es genau umgekehrt aber
wenn man sich genau umgekehrt deswegen
stellten die die Frage okay und da komme
ich jetzt noch mal zum Punkt von Herrn
Palmer schaffen wir falsche Anreize
warum warum sind wir nicht in der Lage
Leute schlichtunter greifen den Arbeit
zu kriegen warum sind wir darin so
schlecht ich glaube wenn wir uns ehrlich
machen muss man die Dinge ein bisschen
sortieren wenn ich Leute erarbeiten
lasse nicht die Fiktion haben sie müssen
wieder zurück sondern die kriegen
vernünftigen Aufenthaltstitel die können
mit ihren wenn Sie Kinder haben hier
leben sie wenn sie sich integrieren wird
das honoriert wenn das die Antwort wäre
wenn du dich integrierst bereit bist
hier zu arbeiten deine Kinder sind hier
du hältst dich an Rechnung gesetzt du
verübst keine Gewalt du integrierst dich
du lernst Deutsch und und arbeitest und
wirst dafür anständig bezahlt da haben
sie nämlich recht also nicht in der
Situation
so wenn ich das mache dann glaube ich
würde ich einen Großteil derjenigen von
den Sirenen Arbeit kriegen das haben wir
aber nicht gemacht schon der Satz wir
sind ein Einwanderungsland und brauchen
Fachkräfte wir reflexartig beantworten
damit du doch erstmal was für die
Deutschen die gibt es auch tun müssen ja
aber wir müssen uns ehrlich machen wir
können überhaupt manche Jobs gar nicht
mehr besetzen wenn wir nicht zu werden
2,5 Millionen Arbeitslose Entschuldigung
ja gut aber ist ja nicht trivial das ist
nicht trivial aber wenn sie angucken
sozusagen was wir auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
nicht hin wir brauchen Fachkräfte
Zuwanderung das müssen wir auch Regeln
und ich glaube die Mischung zu sagen
wenn du dich hier anstrengst wenn du
dich integrierst aber sie brauchen doch
keine Akzeptanz einer Gesellschaft für
solche Leute haben sie Zuwanderung
brauchen sie doch eine Akzeptanz das ist
mein Thema aber wenn sie gepflegt werden
dann ist ihnen auch Schnauze
Nationalität hat mal ganz ehrlich
sondern der Job muss besetzt werden und
deswegen sage ich nochmal ich glaube die
Menschen die sie integrieren wollen
werden akzeptiert ein System
da wäre das mit der SPD zu machen ein
System wie in Dänemark dass man sagt wer
wer dieses Land kommt das machen die
denn so der arbeitet dann auch bitte
bevor wir über einfache Tätigkeiten aber
der arbeitet okay aber ich sag mal bevor
wir
Sitz Zwangsarbeit Redens ist sozusagen
sozusagen
ist doch die Unterstellung die Leute
wollten nicht arbeiten falsch die
meisten brauchen eine ordentliche
Perspektive dann arbeiten Sie das
Zwangsarbeit was ist denn das für
Menschenbild verstehe ich nicht nein ich
finde es ist eine falsche Diskussion zu
sagen wir müssen Arbeit vorschreiben wir
müssen Arbeit vor allen Dingen
ermöglichen und die Menschen integrieren
und wenn wir das ordentlich tun dann
werden die auch akzeptiert wenn nicht
akzeptiert wird Regeln halten sind die
die
gewaltsprache nicht lernen wollen
akzeptiert wir sind da nicht Hersteller
was erlebe ich in meinem Rathaus ich
hatte jetzt in den letzten drei vier
Monaten die Deutschen in den letzten
drei vier Monaten folgende reale Fälle
ein Lagerist bei einem
Sportartikelhändler der ganz Deutschland
beliefert einer der besten Mitarbeiter
abgeschoben ein Mitarbeiter in einem
metallverarbeiten Betrieb fachlich
hochkompetente Firmenchefin bei mir der
muss da bleiben abgeschoben eine
Pflegekraft fertig ausgebildet
haltenhelferin
sitzt bei mir weinend im Büro ihr
Ausländeramt will mich raushaben frage
ich warum ja ich habe leider so
querdinger getroffen die haben mir
erzählt wenn ich mich impfen lasse kann
ich keine Kinder mehr kriegen dann habe
ich meinen Impfpass gefälscht jetzt bin
ich verurteilte Straftäterin zu 90 Tagen
muss ich nach dem Gesetz raus wenn wir
mal im Ausländer haben ziemlich lange
rumfahren Oberbürgermeister das geht
nicht die muss gehen so sagt das Gesetz
bzw was ich gemacht habe ich habe die
die Unterschrift selber gesetzt dass die
Frau hier bleibt wieder nicht verrückt
und schieb eine altenpflegekraft aber
richtig ja weil sie sich für quer denken
kann da irgendwie wieder in die Fänge
geraten ist aber das ist die Lage in der
wird einfach nicht so dass Menschen die
arbeiten in diesem Land belohnt werden
wenn sie haben das ist nicht der
Versuchung die andere das müssen andere
die andere Seite der Wirklichkeit ist ja
dass wir gleichzeitig Stichwort steht
sie kommen schließlich Holstein Menschen
in dem Fall jemand der damit 24 ins Land
gekommen ist ab 25 taucht der in der
Kriminalität Statistik auf in der Akte
Polizeiakte ab 2015 und du kannst sehen
da ist jemand der über fünf Jahre hinweg
erkennbar wirklich keine guten Dinge
veranstaltet in diesem Land und der
eigentlich schon seit fünf Jahren nicht
mehr in dieser Gesellschaft sein sollte
weil wir solche Leute hier nicht haben
wollen die die gewalttätig sind sexuelle
Belästigung Betrügerei das ganze Thema
am Ende sind zwei junge Leute tot und
wir stehen wieder da und fragen uns zu
wiederholten Mal wie konnte das
eigentlich passieren das liegt glaube
ich in Teilen daran dass wir würde ich
mit Herrn Palma argumentieren die
falschen Leute abschieben weil wir die
nehmen die leichter erreichbar sind und
das sind eben solche Leute nicht
zweitens dass wir uns noch nicht genug
Mühe gegeben haben mit anderen Ländern
Abkommen zu schließen dass die Leute
zurücknehmen das einzige was ich
ausschließen würde ist dass wir Menschen
in Länder zurück irgendwo das darf man
nicht tun wir haben nicht die Scharia
sondern das Grundgesetz aber dass man
Gewalttäter hier nicht geduldet dass man
die übrigens den abschieberhaft steckt
und nicht Familien oder andere
ist mal konkret ich habe einen schönen
Satz der da lautet Menschen die die
keinen deren Asylbescheid sozusagen
nicht positiv bewertet wird der nicht
angenommen wird müssen dann auch wieder
aus dem Land raus von wem ist der Satz
Herr Schröder nein
Herr Scholz
ist richtig aber die Frage ist irgendwie
dass das klingt dann so logisch und so
einfach aber was folgt denn aus diesem
Satz dass wir uns Mühe geben müssen die
Dinge anders zu sortieren und noch mal
das fängt das erzählen wir uns seit nein
das zwei jahrzehn Jahre aber wir machen
manche Dinge nicht wir reden immer also
wir fahren seit 1990 also sie angefangen
habe war davon schon die Rede haben wir
immer noch nicht gehört ist richtig aber
der Punkt ist dass wir in Teilen das
Recht glaube ich entschlacken müssen das
Ausländerrecht das muss
bedienungsfreundlicher werden es muss
arbeitsfreundlicher werden nach einer
Einschätzung wir müssen die humanitären
Dinge rausnehmen damit unmittelbar
geholfen werden kann und ich finde wir
müssen das Gewalt Thema von der anderen
Seite betrachten ich finde ja geil kommt
vorbei ja Gewalt darf nicht geduldet
werden Berliner Vorfällen haben wir
sofort wieder in die Debatte gehabt dass
da Vornamen Vornamen Abfragen gemacht
und sind sowas fakt ist eigentlich da
war der Punkt wenn ich das richtig mit
verfolgt habe erstens jungen zweitens
männlich drittens Alko integriert werden
es aus schweren sozialen fansen 5
Migrationshintergrund das waren die fünf
Punkte die eine Rolle gespielt haben
wenn wir sagen würden wir dulden Gewalt
generell nicht egal wer sie verübt egal
gegen wen sie sich richtet egal wie sie
begründet wird das fängt nämlich an
abhanden zu kommen Leute glauben man
kann Gewalt irgendwie bei uns auch
hinnehmen das muss klar unterbunden
werden man muss es mir wieder
gesellschaftlichen Konsens geben erst
recht über uns wenn sich das gegen
Rettungskräfte Polizei Feuerwehr und
solche Leute richtet und dann das gab's
ja auch schon mal das gerade bei
jugendlichen Gewalttätern nach der Tat
auch relativ schnell das Verfahren folgt
und das nicht Monate später passiert